what up guys welcome to the just Harley
thanks YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
unfiltered thoughts where I get ready
while I get ready in the morning so
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in
yeah do all do all that so
today I'm getting ready for a shoot
and guys I just am not good at being a
girl I freaking hate makeup I hate hair
I just do the best I can it's like these
horrible bags under my eyes because I
don't sleep
sorry I'm whining um okay so today
I'm going to be talking about
question I got from one of my followers
on Instagram so if you guys have a lot
of questions you are more than willing
welcome to ask me I might have the wrong
advice I'm out of the right advice
but
this one I think is pretty
straightforward I don't even know why
she was asking me this I thought she was
trolling
this girl asked me
I'm seeing a guy with four different
baby mothers
he won't call Us official like a
relationship
what should I do
so I asked her I'm like you know what
let's let's give her the benefit of the
doubt do you have kids you know like if
she has three different baby daddies
well then if he has three different baby
dad baby mamas that's not so bad you
know what I'm like it's like okay you
know so how many kids do you have none
oh wow okay okay
all right chica
um okay and what what do you see in this
guy is he super successful
um like does he have a house does he
have you know 401k like what what do you
well no
okay
um
um okay so he doesn't have any of that
all right
um
well what what what do you see in him
well we vibe
okay you vibe
aren't there other guys without you know
three different baby mothers so you
could I don't know Vibe with
but we
okay all right
um how old are you you know if she's
like a 45 year old woman like maybe 20 I
think she said 27 28. so let me get this
straight you're childless you're single
you're in your 20s
and you're wasting time
with the dude with not one
not two
but three different baby mothers
are there any other red flags that I
should be aware of well what do you mean
well there's more
he went to
oh
my God I thought I don't know I feel
like this woman was trolling me I was
like you have to be trolling now she
sent a picture of them
now I'm gonna put through this
is it possible that this woman was still
trolling
maybe but I was just like Haram
oh my gosh
it's like
now I don't want to hear
about how
how many
when this goes sour for you I really
don't this is why I have no sympathy you
cannot tell me this was the only guy she
could have dated and I looked at her
profile she wasn't even fat so she's
single childless not fat
no look at she might have had other
issues okay fine
but you can't tell me
that there wasn't
a single
guy she could have dated
so this is why guys
a lot of times people say I'm harsh I
should have more empathy how
can I have empathy when you're dating a
man with three different baby daddies
not one not two but three I'm sorry baby
mamas baby mamas
so then lately I've been responding to
my my female followers okay and I really
never sought out to be an advice Channel
however
and I'm not saying I have a lot to learn
in life
however there's some things that are so
basic like this one girl she asked me
about her Instagram profile now this
girl I would give a solid seven she was
hot and she also
um
oh gosh
She also asked me like what do you think
of my Instagram profile I'm really
looking to meet someone whatever
so I look a little closer
why why okay if you're looking and I'm
like what kind of guy are you looking
for
hard-working traditional tell me why
this girl
head on I'm in short shorts I don't
wanna I'm getting ready okay I don't
want to do that but
it has a booty picture
with their ass on the gram what is he
supposed to think and Now ladies ladies
now this one girl my other girl messaged
me she said
is
my body count too high
am I finished
now I said
what's your body count
like what is it what is it
she says eight
I say Okay
um
now I go on our Instagram
and I say okay
um you know I think I'll you'll be okay
um do you have any evidence of this
online
no okay
go to her Instagram why
why
[Applause]
and she's got this big nose ring what
and to why why
now look I don't I don't know if she was
lying to me telling me the truth it
might have been very much higher but why
are you you marketing yourself as an
Instagram if you're allegedly
not as bad as the Instagram I'll let you
know she's probably like but you guys
see my frustration
it's like
I feel like I don't even need to be an
advice Channel
but there's things that are so basic
that like women seem to not know
now
I've had conversations with relatives
about this and if a Girl Wants
to do what she wants to do put her butt
on the internet
whatever
that's fine I don't really care do what
you want a lot of people were
um surprised that knew me and my you
know before the internet about these
opinions of mine because I'm really not
a judgmental person like if somebody
wants to do I don't really care
well I don't care because I'm not going
to go out of my way to tell you
however I always had my opinions
I might have kept them to myself
however
I have always had
my opinions
so
that's my conclusion today everybody
is that freaking
is that sometimes women want help and so
I tell these girls I you know I tell
them okay you need to take that off of
your Instagram wear nice or cute or quit
like this and I'm not an image
consultant you know you can take what I
say or leave it but
this is just basic basic and
I come back a week later they posted
more ass pictures it's just like
yeah um sometimes people want to be
saved
and sometimes they really don't so you
know take my advice don't take my advice
I don't really care but please stop
wasting my time if you want to ask me
something
and I give you an answer
and you refuse to take the answer it's
just a bit frustrating anyways like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time